education where it's very hard to
communicate and this is a classical
model
of communication complexity it's been
around since the 80s
and what's great about this model is
there's a lot of deep results in this
model
they're super hard but they're useful
because we can use them sort of black
box in all the other models so i really
want to talk about this model this is
the model where
there's somebody named alice and
somebody named bob and they each have an
input
they want to compute some they want to
talk and compute some function okay
it's the function that's on both of
their inputs and the question is
how much do the communication do they
have to have
so that they both know the answer to f
of x y
okay so um this depends on the function
f
but your goal is to minimize the number
of exchanged bits and
sort of magical things can sometimes
happen
in this model for example for some
functions
such as equality trying to test whether
um
x is equal to y this function seems like
something where
alice should have to send her whole
string or bob it should send his whole
string to alice or maybe
alice sends the first half and bob sends
the second half but
somehow it seems like everybody should
somehow all the bits need to get sent
in order for these guys to know that
they're equal but that's not true it
turns out with
constant bits of communication alice and
bob can know if they have the same
string
as long as they're willing to accept
some probability of error
so this is like a magical result on the
other hand
disjointness maybe alice's string
represents
all the items she wants to buy in the
grocery store
so that she has zeros for items she
doesn't want and
she has a one in location i if she wants
to buy the ith item
and bob it's the same with his string y
and now we want to see
is it the case that alice and bob want
to buy any of the same items or is it
the case that
all of the items alice wants are totally
separate from the
items that bob wants okay so this is
called the disjointness problem
that requires omega n bits of
communication
where they're where n is the number of
items okay so that
is a much different problem than
equality and
the issue is these lower bounds are
super hard decades they took decades to
come by
um but and they they use a lot of deep
mathematics but they're super useful
for lower bounds in all of the other
models that i'll talk about
actually every single one of the rest of
the models i talk about
one of the best ways of getting lower
bounds in them come from communication
complexity
okay so let's move to another model here
you can have communication but there's
no space okay what do i mean by no space
this is the data stream model
a data stream is a massive sequence of
data
it's too large to store on disk um
or memory or in your cache or wherever
and it's just sort of flying by and you
have a little bit of local memory where
you can
remember some things that you saw but
certainly not everything that flew by
okay so this is a model that's used
to represent network traffic where
there's lots and lots of packets running
by
you cannot store all the network traffic
that went by your
node but maybe you can keep certain
statistics
about it database transactions sensor
networks
satellite data feed and on and on okay
so usually the model looks like this
there's some data streaming by and
usually you get a single or maybe a
constant number of passes
and your goal is to minimize the local
memory
usage that you need okay so for example
there's a stream of numbers going by
and um you know there's some it's flying
by like a stream
and you want to figure out how many
distinct elements are there
okay so now if you could keep infinite
memory then
you might have noticed that you saw
eight distinct elements
okay but what's amazing about a
streaming algorithm is even if you only
had like
three bits of memory or certainly not
enough to store
all eight names of elements that you saw
you can still keep a good estimate of
how many distinct elements you saw
okay seeing roughly eight you can not
answer you won't know
exactly how many distinct elements you
saw but you'll have a good approximation
okay so this is quite magic and in fact
there's low space algorithms known for
many problems
distinct elements heavy hitters large
wavelet coefficients clustering
all kinds of graph problems and
one technique that's quite useful in
this area is something called
linear sketching where you view the
stream is performing updates to a high
dimensional vector
x uh such as x might tell you if
something's
uh might just be all the possible
elements and telling you if you added an
element or deleted enough
mint and then you compute a sketch which
is really what's the sketch
you pick a random matrix a and you apply
it to this vector x
and the result is a much smaller
dimensional vector
which hopefully contains the information
that you need
and hopefully you can recover the
property perhaps the lp norm or some
other important property
of the original x that you're updating
from
this sketch or this linear
transformation into a much smaller
number of dimensions and hopefully it
still keeps the information there's a
way
of getting the information back from ax
okay
so this motivates one more model called
sketching algorithms
where you have the data you take various
sketches of it sometimes it's
multiplying by a random matrix sometimes
it's something else
you retain the essential information and
because it's smaller
it's easier to compute on it it's easier
to communicate because it's smaller
and it's easier to store okay so these
sketches are important in streaming
distributed and dynamic settings so
these are all ways
of thinking about big data okay so i
talked about
communication i talked about space and
storage
and now i want to talk about time okay
so in this case you don't even get to
see all the data
okay so before you got to see it but you
didn't you know streaming by you didn't
get to remember much
now you don't even get to see it okay
what are you gonna do
well definitely you're gonna have to
compromise and come up with some sort of
approximation um to what you mean by the
right
answer and we're gonna think about two
models one is called the
property testing model and the other is
the traditional approximation
model okay let me start with the second
one because it's more familiar
here there's some the data
is some kind of graph or
a linear program or a large string
or a large function description and what
you want to output is some number that's
close to the value of the optimal
solution
but you don't have enough time to
construct a solution
okay so for example minimum spanning
tree
you get to look at locations that you
carefully choose they might be
sampled randomly or that you may pick a
random starting point and do a breadth
first search or you might do a pick a
random standing point
starting point and do a random walk
these are all techniques that have been
used
so you may want to estimate the minimum
spanning tree estimate a vertex cover
estimate a max cut estimate the solution
to a positive linear program
given two large strings you may want to
estimate their edit distance these are
all things you might want to do
in sub linear time and can be done okay
i mean in sub linear time
all right another type of a compromise
you may make
is instead of trying to estimate a value
i may want to distinguish inputs that
have a specific property
from those that are far from having that
property so i like to think of these as
in the ballpark park versus out of the
ballpark kind of tests
you know in the ballpark means it has
the property
out of the ballpark it's far from having
the property if you're on the edge of
the ballpark kind of swinging off the uh
the lights then they you know it's
you can answer either way okay so i'm
going to give the algorithm leeway
if you're close to having the property
you're allowed to say yes it has the
property
if but you're also allowed to say it
doesn't have the property
either answer is okay okay so those
in-between
inputs that are close you get to answer
either yes it has the property or no it
doesn't
that leeway allows you to answer
questions much faster
and in subline your time so we can use
kind of ideas of sampling
plus algorithms to get much fancier out
much faster
types of results and often this is the
natural question to ask
for example when noise is present and
you're asking
are these points k clusterable you
expect some kind of outlier so you don't
really
you know you don't really expect that
all the points are okay clusterable it's
okay if a few of the points
are not going to fit in one of your k
clusters uh so it's okay to answer yes
it's k
clusterable but it might be good to know
that the noise exists
okay when the data is constantly
changing this might be the reasonable
thing to ask
and it gives a fast sanity check to rule
out very bad inputs
it's also related to the model selection
problem in
machine learning okay so there's a lot
of results known here
for graphs and a lot i'm going to
mention these because some of these are
by the people involved in this project
dense graph project properties we can
tell
for um dense graphs it's completely
characterized what
properties you can test in constant time
okay
and a i'm gonna and this is based on
ideas such as the summary regularity
lemma which is a
a beautiful result in combinatorics for
hyper
finite graphs it's also completely
characterized
this includes planar graphs and other
important classes of graphs that are
more sparse for general sparse graphs
um then there's been a lot of research
but it's more problem by problem we
don't have
a general characterization and this is
an area that's currently being worked on
there's a lot of work on triangle-free
estimating diameter
that's been done but there's a lot more
to do
okay properties of functions lots of
functions have been considered
linearity testing whether a function is
convex or submodular
low complexity trigonomet low degree
total polynomial
monotone lots of types of functions
and i my main point here is just to say
that
the tools that are used come from all
over some of them
are fourier analytic others summaries
irregularity lemma i already mentioned
other tools come from edited number
theory others come from probability
random walks
others are more algorithmic in nature
such as local search
simulating greedy algorithms simulating
parallel algorithms
so the tools really come from all over
and involve
merging all the areas of math
statistics computer science okay
so i want to move to one more model and
here i want to say
a little bit more about it and that's
the case
where there are no samples or not many
samples
okay so here you have distributions on
big domains
you're given samples of a distribution
and
you want to know things such as what's
the entropy
what's the number of distinct elements
what's the shape
uh is it close to uniform gaussian
zippeen
and the question is do you need
assumptions on the shape of the
distribution
operatory um such as is it smooth is it
monotone is it normal
or can you deal without these
assumptions and what we'd like to do
is to to try to use to either minimize
the assumptions
or make no assumptions at all on the
shape of the distribution
so these are large i should mention
discrete domains
and a priori we'd like to make no
assumptions at all
on whether these are smooth
distributions um or anything
such and the question and these are sort
of basic questions
that have been considered in many fields
in statistics and information theory
machine learning databases needs these
algorithms physics biology
so it's all over the place and
there's sort of basic very fundamental
questions
all right the key question that we ask
is how many samples
do you need in terms of the domain size
of the distribution
and the question that is
of interest is do you actually need to
learn the distribution
do you need to estimate the
probabilities of each domain item
because if you do then we know that
learning a distribution needs the domain
size over epsilon squared many samples
okay
so on one hand if you need to estimate
the probabilities of each domain item
in order to figure out whether the
distribution has the property you're
looking for
then we know we need at least linear
in the domain many samples so that's a
lot of samples
or is it possible that the sample
complexity for your testing problem
can be sublinear in the size of the
domain
okay and for the problems that
these problems here all of these cases
the sample complexity for the testing
problem can be sublinear in the size of
the domain
okay so that's um that's the exciting
part about this
area all right so
um just to mention in our usual model
we have some uh probability some
probability distribution p
uh we have a black box that generates
samples we get charged per sample
it's an arbitrary distribution its
domain is again is discrete
we're going to use n to denote the
domain size
it could be the numbers 1 through n it
could be some other domain
which we'll discuss in a minute but
every time i push a button get a new
sample it's going to be an iid sample
from
p the probability that p
assigns to output i p sub i is something
we don't know
we don't have a clue and we also don't
know that p sub i and p sub j
have any a priori relationship to them
and what we're interested in
is our sample complexity in terms of the
domain size
n okay so
properties that have been considered are
things such as
is p the uniform distribution given
samples of p
and samples of q are p and q close or
far
are given samples of p
as a joint distribution is it
independent
uh if p is a set of bits and i keep
getting a bunch of
copies of these bits are those bits do
they have limited independence are they
pairwise or ky is independent
if i think about p and this is something
i'll talk about in a minute
a little bit more if p is a distribution
over an ordered domain
let's say if i is less than j in the
domain
is it the case that probability of i is
always less than or equal to the
probability of j
okay so is there some monotonicity going
on in this distribution
or some other shape structure is p
a hunter distribution or a bayesian
network um
is it compared to how does it look like
an icing model
um is it a determinable point process uh
is it if i have lots of distributions
can i study some joint
properties of these distributions maybe
they're all similar maybe they're all
far
do they all have similar means so lots
and lots and lots of questions
have been considered in this model okay
so i want to talk about a specific
property of monotonicity um
testing monotonicity of distributions
over
the boolean hypercube domain i and
a the boolean hypercube domain um
is we're going to think of each element
of the domain as being
a small d bit string so we have this
d bit string 0 1 to the d the size of
our main
domain is 2 to the d and
in the hypercube domain we have a
partial ordering
we say that domain element x is less
than domain element y
if and only if at each bit
x sub i is less than or equal to y sub i
okay
and we usually draw this picture where
we have a
edge between nodes that differ in
exactly one bit so
0 0 0 has an edge to 1 0 0
another edge to 0 one zero and another
edge to zero zero one
um okay and notice that every node in
the partial order
is smaller than any other node it can
reach by these directed
edges in the partial order so this is
the boolean hypercube
we usually put the um all zero string on
the bottom the all one string on the top
and we separate the notes by level so
level i will have nodes with i ones and
d minus i zeros
okay so that's kind of the picture of
the
boolean hypercube domain and now if we
assign a probability distribution
to the nodes in this domain we'll say
that this probability distribution is
monotone
if whenever the domain element x is less
than domain element y
then the probability we assign to x is
also less than or equal to the
probability we assign to y
okay so that's our definition of a
monotone distribution
over a partial order it's what you would
expect so if
x and y are not related like 0 0 1 and 1
0 0
have no relationship in this partial
order uh then i can say nothing
about p of x versus p of y
okay but if you know if i can reach one
from the other then
i have to be increasing as i go up all
right
so in general you could have level d you
could have d levels um
okay so how are we going to test whether
a distribution
is monotone what we'd like to do
is somehow use learning okay so we'd
like to learn
p hat the only problem is as i mentioned
before
learning distributions takes the size
at least the size of the domain so what
we'd like to do
is learn the distribution assuming that
p
is monotone but we don't know p is
monotone that's exactly what we're
trying to test
okay so still we're going to learn
p hat assuming that p is monotone even
if we don't know that yet
and then what we're going to do is check
that
p hat is close to monotone the thing we
learned
should be close to monotone if p really
was monotone
and also if p hat should be close to p
now why would this why could we even
hope this works
if p really is monotone then when we
learn p
hat assuming p is monotone then p hat
should be close to p
okay and since p is monotone p hat
should be close to monotone
so if p really was monotone everything
should pass
and if p is far from monotone then
either
p hat is also far from monotone
or if p hat is close to monotone and p
is far from monotone then p
hat has to be far from p okay so that's
why we would hope
that such a testing such a paradigm
would work for our testing
and the only question is can we learn
p-hat in sub-linear samples okay that's
not the only question but it's the first
question
can we learn hat p hat in some linear
samples because we just said that
if i don't assume that p is monotone we
need linear samples
okay so somehow using the ps monotone
somehow that should help us let's hope
that that might help us learn p-hat with
some linear samples
now we're not going to get anything
drastically
better remember our domain size is 2 to
the d for the hypercube
the dimension is d so we have 2 to the d
elements in our domain
there's a lower bound of 2 to the 0.15 d
samples that's implied by something
called telegram-like distributions
these are a family of um functions that
come
that are highly studied in combinatorics
and in complexity theory
uh and so we
one can show a lower bound for learning
um that's exponential
in the dimension but it still leaves
open the possibility
that we could have a sub-linear learning
algorithm
okay so that's um in fact what we get
there's a sub-linear learning algorithm
it's sub-linear in the domain size it's
still exponential
in the dimension but you know the the
domain size is exponential and dimension
and this is
less exponential in the dimension okay
so uh i'm going to say a little bit more
about this algorithm in a minute
uh because i think i have a minute um
but
what what this gives us once we say how
we get
got that algorithm is we now can learn p
hat
um in sub linear samples we can check
that p hat
is close to monotone here we're going to
have a complete description of p hat
no further samples will be needed we can
use some sort of
linear program or some proof for search
the only thing i should mention at this
point
is the learning algorithm though it's
sublinear samples
it's actually super linear time so the
search for a sublingual time and sub
linear sample
algorithm for testing and learning
monotonicity is still
open so something good to work on okay
now so no further samples are needed to
check that p
hat is close to monotone that's purely a
computational problem
um to check that p hat is close to p
is the big bottleneck because there we
need
some tolerance we know that p hat is not
exactly p
and it turns out that this is something
we can do in sub linear time just barely
and over log n samples and it's similar
to an analysis of valiant and value
so this is the bottleneck and if one can
improve this
then one can improve the whole paradigm
all right so this gives an order n over
login sample
monotonicity testing algorithm and in i
think
one in a couple of minutes i have
remaining i'm just going to say a word
about this monotone algorithm to talk
about this algorithm i have to define
something called tight and slacky
elements
so remember that if f is monotone then
the function value at
x has to be at least as big as the
as all of its predecessors okay so
it's max over all predecessors y f of y
now we're going to say x is tight if
if we have equality in this
in this relationship but so f of x is
just what it needs to be
to be bigger than its predecessors but
otherwise we're going to say
x is slacky meaning f x is not only
bigger than all of its predecessors
but it's even a little bit bigger okay
so there's some slack
involved in x in f of x so here's an
example
if you take the distribution p that's
uniform in the upper half
and zero on the bottom half this is a
monotone distribution
but if you take a domain element that's
right in the middle
it's the bottom part of the upper half
the bottom level of the upper half
then we see that a its value is 2 over 2
to the n
but all of its predecessors have value 0
so this is a slacky element
okay if we take something from either
the bottom half in the middle or the top
half
but not the bottom row of the top half
then
i it's going to be exactly equal to the
values of its predecessors and these
guys we call
tight okay so
motivation to this learning algorithm is
actually a lemma
from a computational complexity result
by place at all and i'm going to restate
it but consider any monotone
function this is a boolean function then
you can take this function which has
tight and slacky elements all over
and you can rewrite it
or approximate it by a function that has
slacky elements only at a constant
number of special levels
okay and part of the work
is to extend this to be useful for
probability distributions i'm not going
to
mention how but why is this actually
interesting
um well if you have very few slacky
levels
so very few then most elements not only
are tight but they're far from slacky
levels
okay so x is tight most elements are
tight
and they're actually pretty far from
slacky levels so what
you can notice though is if i want to
figure out what is the value of
x i can look at its largest predecessor
at its next at the next slacky level
below it
okay so i can check all the different
y's on this level
and notice that um why
the if i look at the largest predecessor
then p of x and p of y
have to be identical because x is tight
and everything in here is tight and this
is the first place that's slacky
so all of these guys have to have the
same value
okay which means that the probability
distribution is constant in this diamond
and since these x is kind of far from
slacky i mean this
is not going to work so i should say
this is
this is true for all x in between the
slacky levels
but what's interesting about x that's a
little bit far from this lackey level
is that if i take enough samples i'm
likely to land in here
and i can estimate the probability the
total probability of this diamond
and then divide by the number of points
in this diamond
okay so i once i take enough samples i'm
likely to fall in this diamond and have
a pretty good estimate
of the average probability in this
diamond so i can
figure out what's p of x okay
and i can do this um so there's a you
know
this is true for the largest predecessor
that everything is constant
it's not true for the other predecessors
but if we just take
the maximum average probability that's a
good estimate of p of x
and that's how we're going to learn
we're going to go through every single x
we're going to go compare it to a
for every single x um and we're gonna do
this diamond
type thing and figure out the maximum
value to its next slacky level
um and that's the probability we're
gonna
do for x so we're gonna try y y prime z
z prime all of the different values here
all the ones that precede x look at the
diamonds
the one that gets the largest average
that's the one we're going to assign
as p of x okay now this is going to work
really well for those x's that are far
enough away from the slacky level
that i have enough samples in here to
estimate it it's not going to work so
great for the x's here
but notice that you know there's not
that many slacky levels that i'm
going to mess up there's not that many
levels there's not
many points right above the slacking
levels most points are kind of far from
a slacky level
because we have so few slacky levels so
this actually gives a really good
algorithm
and that's the basis okay so that's all
i have to say about that because i'm
running out of time it's good
i just want to mention there's a lot of
directions that we're considering in the
fodzy
um proposal so things such as mergiable
summaries for
statistics numerical linear algebra
random projections for complex
clustering problems sub linear sampling
bounds for structured high dimensional
distribution
and lots of other directions
okay so in conclusion i want to say some
linear problems are everywhere
for many of these problems we need a lot
fewer resources than you might think
and there's really a lot of cool ideas
and techniques and there's very strong
connections between
math cs and statistics in the techniques
okay
so um uh if we have any
quick questions you can pop them in the
q a and while folks are thinking about
that
uh maybe martin could set up his screen
sharing should i stop sure yeah that
would be great
thanks ronnie
all right so um
looks like no no no questions it's time
to move
to martin's talk thanks thanks again
ronnie so
um uh the